ashley mcbride it's great to see you
good morning congratulations
yeah what did you think when they asked
you to co-host this show
i was nervous immediately and i've
always wanted to host or present in some
way
and so i said yes of course
automatically but i've been butterflies
what are you looking forward to most
tonight
um i after meeting sarah highland over
zoom doing
uh read-throughs and things so we can
get this right i'm most looking forward
to hosting
with her she is such a sweetheart and so
good at this and she makes it
easy to relax and come calm down and
slow down
and read the teleprompter correctly yeah
yeah you already have
your fair share of awards um and from
what i understand
that you keep them in a very special
place where do you keep them
they are safe they are in my guest
bathroom downstairs there in the hallway
um everybody has to use that room at
some point when they come over to the
house
and some people have actually um picked
up the the awards off the shelf and
taken selfies
with them and done speeches with them in
the house was this a very specific
strategy
how do people react
yeah when i very first won my very first
award i placed it there
on a shelf in my bathroom and then i put
post-it notes on the wall
for um place acm here place cma here and
trying to manifest and
do some healthy thinking like that and
so people would come in and be like
there's one award on the wall and a
bunch of post-it notes i'm like i know
i'll swap them out the last time i
talked to you which was i think at the
end of 2018
you were nominated for your first grammy
nomination
a lot has changed since then ashley
everything has changed since then at the
end of 2018 when you and i were sitting
in that really cool
dive bar yeah then things started taking
off and then all through 2019 it was
just
up up up up the momentum was insane
um a gold record i got a number one in
canada and i'd never had a top ten
before in the united states so
everything just really started taking
off
that's how i met you also mcbride this
is gail speaking when
when anthony did the piece with you i
said who is that girl
i like your music so much i've been a
fan ever since the one night standard
just sort of blows me away i the one
one night standards i love that song but
this is the thing you've got three songs
connected it's involving a cheater
cheater pumpkin eater and a shovel
how did you come up with that concept
because i love the video
yes it's a great video it is a good
video um i didn't
thanks i didn't plan initially to string
those three
um songs together but what wound up
happening was one night i was trying to
string
everything on the record together what
if it all happened kind of in one place
and wound up seeing that martha devine
was actually going to be
the main character of one night
standards but we wouldn't know that
until the second video
um and then it wound up being all three
so one night standards martha devine
followed by hang in there girl where we
hide the evidence it was a lot of fun i
didn't think they were gonna let me do
that concept and they did and so
i was really really excited especially
when i said
can we swing a shovel yeah inside this
house
absolutely i won't even tell people what
the video is you got to see it for
yourself but
during this pandemic i always hear about
a lot of creative types that say they're
writing more they're thinking more
how are you navigating getting through
this in 2020
initially when everything stopped it was
really hard to adjust
and it wasn't a very creative time for
me and i just kind of got down in the
dumps
and then when i realized this this
wasn't gonna go away this was a real
thing that we really needed to
to handle i put on my big girl boots and
and got up every day with a purpose
to write a song every day the way you're
supposed to
i became a part of the couch for over a
month and that's just not acceptable
so it's much better now that
everything's moving in here and doing
what it's supposed to do
i know what it feels like to be part of
the couch i want to ask you one thing
next week you're also going to be part
of the big night benefit
for the country music hall of fame and
museum and you get to play
loretta lynn's 1956 gibson j50 guitar
what does that mean to you
i was worried when i first picked it up
because no no hands have touched that
guitar except um in linen gloves
and i was worried initially when they
told me i could pick it up because i
didn't want to get the oils from
my skin on the neck of her guitar it's
incredible
the guitar is awesome and being in the
hall of fame playing a song of hers that
i love so much when you're looking at me
you're looking at country
such a great statement she made and i i
was it was nerve-wracking
but i can't wait to see the whole thing
put together yeah ashley
can i just say good luck tomorrow night
and isn't reading the prompter fun it's
just so much fun
and i once i discovered it's not going
to outrun me because i was trying to
read it so fast
they're so nice at cmt and they were
like ashley can you please slow down
i'm trying ashley i'm so excited for you
thanks so much for being with us this
morning
the 2020 cmt music awards to be with you
yes it was well there it will air
tomorrow night at 8
7 central on the cmt a division of
viacom cbs